oh totally late may I apologize to you
guys not really you know it's okay if
I'm late to my own show
I don't know where you guys got this
concept where I can't be late to my own
show I got to get the rest of the people
in here all right I want to leave you
guys in here hanging without knowing to
talk to I am 16 minutes late
so let me get them in here real quick
you have to bear with me man you ought
to bear with me
all right
just give me a second guys
I took my mom
to my girlfriend's house uh
and I couldn't get when I came back
I just I hit into some traffic and stuff
I apologize you know regardless if I can
be late to my own show you know I still
shouldn't be like you know I
I personally feel like I've done a
fantastic job not being late okay I
think I'm entitled to one to one
you hear me till one
now let me switch cameras
you guys should still be able to hear me
you just can't see me
because I have to switch to zoom
there we go
now you should be able to see me as well
oh
now I just gotta wait for the peoples
look at that man see that's why I like
dirt
hold up dirt you are live by the way
you know I had to pop in here because uh
I decided to be mad late
give me one second
okay
all right no you're fine man go get your
water
all right all right all right
now
we should all be hearing things and all
should be fine oh
I'm in a good mood today I don't know
why
technically
it's been chaos today
I shouldn't be in such a good move good
mood mood
what are you guys doing man
you know this is a little bit of a
pre-show just a little bit of a pre-so
yeah well actually
it shouldn't be a pre-show
I think uh
I think we need some stuff do you think
I think we need
some new graphics on the podcast man
bam
see look man we've been here 16 minutes
that's that's my
now why isn't Zoom working correctly
what
well Zoom was working
and now it's not
okay there we go
alrighty
all right we are live by the way dirt
oh yeah
yeah sorry I was late man I I ended up
getting stuck in some traffic it was it
was a nightmare uh I don't know
where bitcloud is you know the Cloud's
usually never here so that that doesn't
surprise anybody definitely doesn't
surprise me he he might show up later
who knows you know big cloud uh he he a
busy dude he a busy dude but we got dirt
what's going on Dirk
what's up brother how you doing my man
doing pretty
good
you know I was watching um
I was watching Suits earlier today so I
needed to make sure I got home and then
my mom needed to go somewhere so it's
just a lot of running around man a lot
of running around to do I thought I'd
get here on time but I I was on don't
you it wasn't too bad you always
underestimate how much driving you have
to do until you actually do it like how
long it like realistically takes you all
right so this is the deal with you guys
uh we are in the in the talks right now
to having it uh actually you know what
wait for ILP Sunday 1 p.m I'm gonna tell
you guys some nice stuff you're gonna
wanna hear all right that's Sunday
though this is Wednesday but welcome to
the attic show well we talk about the
past present future game I got my codes
with me Dirk griggity what you been
playing Dirk
oh man I actually been playing a lot of
games lately my brother been playing
plagixtail Requiem love it absolutely
incredible
all right I've been playing got the
license
got them nice it's not bad
yeah it's not bad no
all right so you know it's really pretty
decent it's much better than the
Metacritic score I I actually like I
like it but I put it down to 100 focus
on plays tail requiem once I finish with
that I'll go back to Gotham nice and I
also be playing some Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 campaign
you got to say it in the cold voice
yeah I'll be playing some call to do
this sucker
jive turkey
oh my God two dollars uh Super Chat from
flame addict showed up oh dear also hey
y'all what's going on flame what's going
on
I can either confirm or deny I was like
to me
dirt I feel like we was on time and
everyone else was like yeah they were
early you were early you you were
showing off so how was it my fault
everyone in the chat wanted to be early
like 16 minutes instead of being on time
that's that's besides the point all
right so we got a good show for you guys
man if you look in the description
you'll see all the topics uh you'll also
see the time steps to zero zero zero
they will be updated throughout the
podcast to avoid being attacked by what
we call the time stamp Mafia I
understand Mafia man they on your head
man we're going to be talking about
kojima's new game no we're gonna [ __ ] an
Xbox series s
uh there's a lot of things going on with
them actually right now we're going to
be talking about red fall
remastered uh City because I feel like
there's a lot of remasters going on you
know I want to briefly talk about
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing and Xbox game pass
being profitable oh mostly we all talk
about that wait a minute Mr addict sir
did you say Xbox game pass is profitable
no I did I did I did and I will
all right so you know first off I want
to appreciate the 107 people already in
here definitely hit that like button if
you guys don't mind let's get those
likes up a little bit uh always helpful
definitely share this to Twitter tell
people addicts live don't tell them I
was late though all right just tell them
I'm live if you tell them I'm late I
look incompetent and that's where I have
an issue with but anyway let's go and
get on with this man you know let me
edit this let me edit this I gotta
switch accounts real quick because uh
you know unlike you guys I'm actually
generally scared of the time step Mafia
you know they'll come here any minute
and just and just get me up out of here
man and you know I like my life you know
some days
it is what it is but I like my life uh
so we're gonna start at eight minutes
and 10 seconds we we start in the first
topic zero eight
ten seconds all right so kojima's game
have you seen uh what he's referring it
as
dark Gregory have you seen it yeah I'm
trying to remember because I read it
earlier he said it's a uh medium what do
you say something yeah a new medium it's
kind of like a new medium oh yeah we do
have to keep in mind that this game is
going to be most likely an Xbox game
because uh I think his next game is
unless he's semi talking about uh you
know death straining two which he could
be working on another game I think this
is the game he's working on with that
with Xbox
um I'm not a big fan of Kojima I've
always felt like he's overrated that's
just me personally yeah I have made
jokes in the past that he belongs in a
stray jacket obviously he's jokes but uh
you know people seem to think I'm being
serious when I say stuff like that it's
just the internet folks calm down but
when he's saying something like it's
like medium but better
I'm I'm still not there like I I didn't
really I wasn't really sold on medium in
first place so when you've when you hear
Kojima working on something maybe
relatedly close to medium of how the
story's infrastructure maybe or maybe
how the game infrastructure is with the
gameplay mechanics does that get you
hype or are you just like okay
well I'm gonna tell you um
something I liked about that game was
the
you know like the
two I don't know how like I don't know
how to even describe it but how two
things was happening at the same time
but one was in the current world the
other one was in whatever the other
world was realm or whatever you call it
um listen man I like hojima but
I've said it several times his last two
games I did not like
the up surrounding and metal gear solid
five and I love the metal against all
the franchise but part five just uh I
didn't like it at all
um look if this is an Xbox game if it's
a PlayStation game because I see him
taking pictures with Jim Ryan and Herman
Holst and those folks also and we heard
a rumor about death stranding too
um that's cool but I don't know man he
wants to do something with Cloud
technology so that's why he's working
with Xbox we heard he was trying to work
with Stadium but
um you know that obviously didn't work
out so I'm curious to see what it's
going to be I'm curious to see because
even though he's kind of out there
sometimes
he can be original
and um sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't so I'm I'm definitely curious
let me see I will say you can't get more
original than a UPS simulator because I
can't name another one of those that's
exactly it was pretty of damn original
you know but I'll tell you one thing
about him his cut scenes his games are
pretty damn good
yeah that's why I feel like he
he wants to be more
in like
The Cinematic Universe that anything he
wants to be like a cinematic person he
wants to make movies TV shows and I feel
like that's where his heart truly
belongs but he loves gaming too so he
tries to add them two together and it's
just like I personally feel like his
ideals don't result good into good
gameplay
you know and as much as this is going to
sound bad I feel like uh Konami kept
like the Kojima in check
right right well during those little
meetings they were sitting there looking
at like kojimo say something konami's
like Kojima that makes no sense
oh so we can't know Kojima that what
what place does that feel like that
would be fun to play
yeah you right maybe we should downplay
this a little bit like
he needs the filter like yeah
nobody's gonna buy that
yeah but you know
the one thing I will say is people like
that will surprise you
yeah they'll make experiences that you
didn't even think was possible I
honestly do feel like Kojima is the only
person that can make a horror game
to the degree where I myself as a 30
year old man wouldn't have to be to be
scared during horror game you know what
I'm saying because people will get this
weird misconception that jump scares and
horror are the two same thing no they're
not no it's not like just because you
make me jump a couple times like I want
that I'm watching something or playing
something I have I have like this chill
in the back of my spine that's just like
I don't want to go down there they're
scary that's not where attic belongs
but
there's not very many games that do that
and there's not much TV shows that do
that it's not much movies that do that
but I do feel like Kojima has the
creativity and the freedom of of
whatever his mind is considered because
it's you know whatever he's on sometimes
I want it you know I do I do feel like
he has the ability to make that type of
game
absolutely because I'm gonna tell you
that PT demo was one of the scariest
things I ever played
you know I never played that yeah I
played it I downloaded when it first
came out I was like holy [ __ ] it was
pretty scary bro apparently they were
all like people on online was offering
people like a sizable amount of money
for our PlayStation 3 that had that on
it or PS4 I can't remember if it was PS4
or PS3 it was four it was four PS4 that
had that on it like you can get a
sizable paycheck if you had that on I'm
sad because I actually had it right I
still had the demo
um but I had gave my oldest daughter my
PS4 when I had got a PS4 Pro and I don't
know what she did with it bro I actually
asked her does she still have that yeah
I actually really asked for that because
to like she's a PC Gamer now but wasn't
that supposed to be a silent hill game
it was supposed to be Asylum Hill you
have Silent Hills yeah you know we could
talk about that real quick uh I'm not
putting that in the time stamp Mafia
you're gonna have to get over that I'm
not re-time stamping
um how do you feel about the Silent Hill
in Resident Evil thing that's coming up
actually hold up we'll put that in the
remaster that's what we'll do we'll put
that in the remaster because when it
comes to the Kojima thing honestly don't
think there's a whole lot we could talk
about Kojima there we do need it because
we don't know anything we do need to see
more from the title uh but I do feel
like If kojima's part of it it's good
for Xbox because I do feel like Kojima
actually has a decent sized audience
that
it takes someone like Kojima making to
get them to try the Xbox device yeah uh
and I feel like they will uh have you
ever met a hardcore Kojima fan
they're like a force of nature yeah like
like a hurricane can't do nothing to
them
like they speak and and it starts
tsunamis like it's crazy how how much
power is given to these these Kojima
fans right I I actually I don't know how
you feel about this I personally feel
like Kojima you know because people keep
saying Microsoft Biko jima's company
haven't make exclusive games they're
like no Microsoft baikujima's company
and have him
uh and have him choose his successor
well he could still work there but I
feel like you need him more to manage
Japanese Studios than you need him to
make a game for you because he's got a
lot of connections a lot of people
respect him and you get a lot of you can
he I honestly believe if he was
motivated enough he could move mountains
in the Japanese area for Microsoft yeah
it's like you know when you buy he's a
legend yeah he's a legend over there
yeah if they're not gonna buy a
publisher in the Japanese area or the
you know the the eastern part of the
world in general
get someone like ojima someone that's
well respected has a lot of uh has a lot
of connections and have him
pretty much take a Peter uh a Peter
Hines position over there and he'll
manage a bunch of Studios that Microsoft
puts under his brand
and obviously you know
Kojima please don't try to put your
nonsense on every game that you manage
like you know like that's the issue
because he's a creative guy he probably
still want to do some creative stuff you
know
but you know that's what I feel like I
do feel like they're eventually going to
buy a company over there I don't know if
it's gonna be Sega uh you know maybe
even Konami uh because you know you can
say what you want about Konami Konami
owns a lot of very popular IPS yeah they
own um the Metal Gear Solid franchise
I'm pretty sure they own the Castlevania
franchise they own the
um Silent Hill they actually own uh I
think they're one of the lead Publishers
to Yu-Gi-Oh too so I don't know if they
own Yu-Gi-Oh I think they might just be
like one of the partners with Yu-Gi-Oh
I'm not really 100 sure on that uh but
you know
it is what it is when it comes to stuff
like that I I do personally feel like uh
Kojima is going to do what Kojima is
there ain't nothing I could say in this
segment but that's it I think uh I think
this next segment is something that you
would definitely like to talk about uh
dirt and you know what that segment is
what's that my man we have been seeing
the Xbox series s and a lot of uh
slander here recently uh but what I want
to talk about is a couple things with
the series that's I want to briefly go
over again the individual uh that was
talking about the the series X uh the
series s and the capabilities that that
game has the system has and I also want
to talk about something that I saw
uh the the CEO of Microsoft said or it
was someone over there it may be in
marketing I I think it was Saturday I
don't know but he was saying that
the majority of the customers buying the
series s aren't console owners in
general they've never bought a console
and that was their plan all along yeah
um but I also saw like satin and Della
say that half of the Xbox series s
owners are new to Xbox ecosystem period
yes so that's probably what it was half
of the uh the people are new because
it's so
it seems like that's working because I
do feel like as much okay I will say I'm
gonna say that I am concerned with the
series s in terms of keeping up with the
PS5 and the Xbox series X in long term
like okay mid gin light gin I am
concerned about that but we gotta see
that before we can really broke first
into it too much but
I don't think the series s was designed
for these AAA uh double A these AAA
games uh you know it they'll run them uh
but I think it was mainly designed to be
user friendly to be cheap so they can
get it out the door as fast as they can
and to be able
to be a Game Pass machine that you can
uh that you can botch in maybe a month
of Game Pass with and you can walk out
of there with you know someone goes in
there that gets 2ks the maddens and they
get a series s and they walk into a box
yeah casual box that that's what I
personally feel like look are there
people that's going to own this that's
going to have a lot of issues because
it's not running correctly in certain
games and you know sometimes you have to
wait a couple months after the game
comes out yes but I do feel like it I
don't know about you dirt but wouldn't
it be a correct assumption from our
standpoint to say that the people that
would care the most they have the ex
absolutely that's exactly what I feel is
I think you're right about this
I I believe Microsoft's strategy was to
make it a casual box right
um this holiday we've already seen some
sales papers off it's going to be 239. I
I don't know if it was Target I believe
it was Target they had it for 2.99 but
it comes with Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2. so
I believe their strategy was to make it
the Casual box now uh your concern you
know later down the line of it being
able to run AAA
like huge AAA games well I mean that's a
valid concern I
just let me I think I'm mainly concerned
about like Elder Scrolls six how's that
going to run on the series s you know
game like games to that size or maybe
another Gotham Knights that you know I
personally feel like they could have
probably got this working if they would
have had more time I think it's more
time restraint than anything but what
happens when you want to make
um you know stated Decay 3 untethered
but the the series s can't handle it so
the X can't be untethered just the S be
tethered and the X can't I do feel like
that is a conversation worth having
me yeah down the line you know that's
something maybe uh I just feel that I
don't know I just feel like Microsoft
knows what they're doing for some reason
I just feel like in 2025
uh you know like around there I don't
think there's gonna be games that can't
run on the Xbox series s
will like we know the resolution will
always be lower
um maybe sometimes the frame rate might
not be up to part with the Xbox series X
and the PS5 right now for the most part
the frame rates have seemed to be
keeping up with it
um you know so I mean like these are
valid questions that you're asking
I just feel like Microsoft knows what
they're doing um I'm not sure if it's
something in the future some software
feature they can add because I know they
just added recently this added some more
was it Ram
um or memory or something recently They
just added something like a small small
portion of memory um so maybe something
on a GPU side can be affected in the
future
I don't know man so I don't know but I
do believe it it was definitely made to
be a casual box like you said there's
people that literally play 2K Madden in
Call of Duty that's it
that's it
and I think that and I believe those
games will be fine not to mention
fortnite all the kinds of people that
just want to play fortnite
300 you out
uh you know regardless how you feel
about is the Xbox series escalating and
I think that's the biggest question is
is like the developer is going to take
the time to make sure it runs correctly
on it I do think the console can do it
if it's actually correctly done no I'm
not saying no yeah I'm not saying I know
how to do anything like that or the
structures to going on but from the
developers I've talked to it says look
it takes a little bit more time but for
the most part these games are made to
run on the series s because they're uh
because they're made to run on weaker
weaker Hardware such as like you know
1080 soft hardware and stuff that you
got on PC uh you know they don't run
good but they they have to run them to a
point
yeah I mean like just like with PC games
you know if you look on it you know
usually says minimum specs
you know meaning this game will not run
if it's lower than these specs and I
believe I saw Jeff Grubb say this on
Twitter that we would never get that
huge jump in Generations that we got in
the past I always remember the PS2
original Xbox to the 360 was a massive
jump
um the PS1 to the PS2 was a huge jump
and what Jeff grow up said I could be
mistaken but I believe it was him
um
the budgets of these games
will probably prevent us from having
that massive jump
that's what he said something like that
I'm I'm paraphrasing here because the
budgets are already extremely expensive
for those huge jumps that we're that we
want
no I'm not sure if it's going to go that
way but playing the place tell Requiem
that game looks incredible
it looks pretty damn good have you
played it yet
no it's 30 frames
yeah it is it is yeah I I I have stood
on my stack of newspapers
and I'm scrimming from my microphone
that unless I care about you I'm not
playing no game at 30 frames I think we
might get more 30 frame games in the
future too to be honest with you
please don't be I just have a feeling
look I don't mind if we get the
occasional one but it's just like I
don't want to see every other one
yeah it's just like like it was last
year yeah and what's crazy is I I'm
willing to put money on it dirt and I
don't know how you feel about this
but I'm really going to say in the next
six months is going to be a patch making
Gotham night 60 frames on both the PS5
and series X and the series s
and then they're gonna be like oh it was
like this the whole time please buy your
sick game
hey you know Warner Brothers themselves
they they've lost their way
things going on with them bro Dave
because they just lost like what four
people like a co-found they're
co-founders and the leader you know the
co-founders in the studio heads too or
were they the same people I I think I
think it's the same people they even
look it up I believe it's the same
people
all right while you read that I'm gonna
read this five dollar Superstar Cowboy
uh coward weeb uh probably butchered
that my bad oh I got it I got it okay
the Xbox series S is doing what it was
designed to do replace the Xbox One
Elder Scrolls 6 will be fine considering
the CPU is responsible for drawing the
world yeah I think it's a Memory
restraint too I think a lot of people
are having memory issues on the series
yeah it is less memory than the X
um oh yeah you're right there the
co-founders and Studio heads of
Rocksteady something's going on I don't
want to change I don't want to mess up
your time stamps but
think about Gotham Knights their last
game was Batman Origins from 2013.
bro this is literally uh this is what
nine years it took them nine years to
make a game
well I um totally do something else
between them I think the people working
they were working on suicide squad
weren't they
yeah
no no Rock's daddy was making Suicide
Squad I'm talking about the people WB
Montreal are the ones today no no like
the ones that made guys are nice I'm
talking about the team bro Batman orders
was their last game for 2013 it's been
nine years
something's not right over there yeah we
still have like no real additional
information on the Wonder Woman game
either like besides that initial
announcement I haven't really seen
nothing from them and what's funny is
they have some of the most iconic IPS
and brands that they can work with and
somehow they keep dropping the ball
yeah
I mean I mean that's something to talk
about I mean that's something to think
about even with Rocksteady
Batman Arkham Knight came out in 2015.
so it's been seven years with that game
so what's what's taking so long you know
what I'm saying
it is what it is uh
uh when did the Justice 2 come out
Injustice is a different story though I
think that that's for another round yeah
nether Realms doing the bulk of that
it's like creative assembly in 343
working on Halo Wars sure it was 343
code developing that game yes but I'm
interested if you actually found people
that worked on Halo Wars you will
probably find out Halo Wars 2 was mainly
designed by creative assembly I think
it's like one of those things where if
they were to make any type of lore
adjustments or anything related to how
the game presents itself for the world
presents itself they would need 343's
permission to do that
yeah
oh Wonder oh please murder please don't
be it's it's
Harry Potter 30 frames
I don't think they said yet have they oh
my God if it's 30 frames I'm gonna be so
upset you just you just messed up my
whole day murder my day was looking so
good and now you just messed it up you
just spit in my face murder how does it
feel to know you spitting addict's face
on the game he was looking forward to
all right so uh let's I mean when it
comes down to it man the series S I do
feel like
if you want the series s
there's a reason you wanted that for it
no I'm honestly thinking that the
majority of Hardcore Gamers people that
actually you know play games people that
bought the series the Xbox One X and the
Xbox One S they're not going out there
and buying the Xbox or the Xbox series s
they're they're buying
the console that fits them
yeah the X like we bought the X where
we're hardcore Gamers right but I'm
going to tell you what the more the ass
sale the more developers are going to
shut up and develop for it
um like I always say I know the Nintendo
switch doesn't have all of the huge AAA
third-party games
but they have some of them I haven't
heard one developer complaining about
the Nintendo switch
yeah I think too is
you know
what we said last week
sometimes these uh these Fanboys uh girl
can get a job
saying this dude wasn't a fanboy but uh
the way he acted was mad unprofessional
it just was like you know
you you do and you know what I love when
people sit there and say that you're
you're faking something you're not being
genuine there's a difference between
being professional being disrespectful
you can be professional without
abandoning your morals and people act
like you can't right it's just it's just
crazy like you know I don't like the the
Xbox series s and the reason I don't
like is because I don't I want the
console
that I want and the x is what I want so
why would I care what people buy with
the series s
uh and you know I think the biggest
reason that I don't like like the the
lower tier stuff is because when I was
playing
gears five and I think I may have told
you this a long time ago I don't know I
was playing gears five with uh with kid
smooth I was on the Xbox One S he was on
the Xbox One X
and I've said this in the chat so I'm
sure some of you in this chat has heard
this story until this day I got I got
flashbacks from it but I'm sitting there
we die I mean it was in one of the snowy
areas like use a below break or
something like that I don't know I die
he dies
Dirk tell me how this man revised first
he comes back first and tell me how it
took like a minute and a half for me to
come back damn kids no no I'm not saying
that you know he came up and it was just
sitting there what I'm saying is the
game was running and I was sitting there
on the loading screen why kid smooth is
walking around
and there's there's there's there's
enemies everywhere coming out kids moves
literally have to keep me alive while
I'm getting out of the loading screen
so ever since then I'm not doing these
lower gen consoles anymore these lower
uh tier consoles anymore if there's a
higher tier console addicts will be on
the console that does not do that to me
anymore
it is
yeah see but but like back to what we
said those because these like the S
isn't for guys like us though you know
what I'm saying it's for our kids it
it's for like my father I I had an Xbox
series s right I went to GameStop I
traded my Xbox One X I said how much
y'all gave me for this it gave me
something like 260 dollars for it so I
said cool so I got my Xbox series as put
it in the family room wasn't really
planted up there gave my father who's 74
years old but he still you know he's a
casual he loves Magna he loves it it
might be the show
so yo man give me that PS4 slim take
this Xbox series s
and it's perfect for him because he
don't even have a 4K TV he's playing on
a 720p TV but he's fine he's fine he
loves it so like I said the X isn't for
us man it's for our kids and you know
stuff like that it's it's about
people because I do feel like Microsoft
to a point understands the demographic
of people that buys these consoles
uh people like us we're going to inform
our hardcore friends like I couldn't
tell you one of my hardcore friends that
I play college or Not Call of Duty I
hate that damn game that I play
OverWatch with that I play Destiny with
that I play any game known to man and
they tell me they have a series s but I
could tell you a lot of kids that have a
series I could tell you A lot of people
that only play 2K have some serious
asses and I think that's you're gonna
see a huge
a huge push for to make sure that those
games run the best they possibly can on
the series s absolutely I mean that's
exactly what I'm saying it's going to
sell bro it's going to sell and
it's like the more sale the more these
companies are going to say okay
we got to just develop for this thing
flat out we have to develop for this
thing because there's millions of those
consoles out there in a while
and
if you want to play on a like a bad
performance system play on the switch
because I I I'm right now I was bullied
into playing Mario and rabbits Sparks I
hope I have to review it for IOP
and I'm sitting there I'm you know I'm
going to keep my reserves for the game
but I'm just like why is this game Run
so bad
I I dude I could literally I can make a
YouTube video in the time it takes for
to for the loading screens like and it's
just like when you play games on that
kind of console or like a really really
outdated PC you start to really
and truly understand okay maybe this
ain't so bad like of course bro Nintendo
don't give a damn
they will make a console however they
see fit and tell the developers develop
for it the GameCube remember
those I don't know how much memory those
little small discs even held but it
wasn't as much as a DVD from the PS2 and
the Xbox
um they just don't care like yo develop
for this weird Nintendo whatever we make
I don't know if you've ever heard the
story uh Nintendo Wii is kind of why
Sonic 2006 out of the heads are 2006
turn out to be how it was I don't know
if you heard that story
because uh Sega was going to make it the
same across the board but when they got
specs for the Nintendo Wii basically
holy crap this thing is weak as hell so
they had to put they had to take some of
the team off of the PS3 and the Xbox 360
version of Sonic 2006 and make a special
team for the Wii version and then that
messed around and messed the whole
project up you know so I mean it's a
great YouTube video you gotta look that
up that's why signing 2006 turned out to
be a buggy mess because they didn't have
enough time you know it's crazy too
speaking of Sonic you know Sonic was
originally supposed to be the mask card
effects box
really I didn't hear that really they
they went out they they wanted Sonic to
be the actual
uh mascot like the original mascot uh
but they couldn't agree the terms of
buying Sega
I don't know if they were trying to buy
Sega or just Sonic it was one or the
other uh you know because back then
Microsoft was a little bit open just to
to spending money not as open now
clearly uh but yeah it's just funny it's
funny how things how things Rock
all right so let's go and move on uh
let's let's talk about redfall did you
see that gameplay that dropped yes I did
Sir how are you feeling about that
gameplay that dropped today and I
thought the time stamp Mafia I'm putting
yeah 36 minutes and 45 seconds there you
go oh what is that chick's name again
Layla
Allison I believe
something like that
I thought it looked incredible bro yeah
I think that's incredible I I'm still
very
very cautious and I think it's mainly me
cautious because I don't want that type
of game for Markham uh uh Arkham
Arcane yeah Arcane I want more like
death Loop Dishonored did you did you
hear that they put the the
the Dishonored and death Loop are in the
same universe yeah so right there them
doing that gives me hope they're going
to do another Dishonored why would you
put them in the same everywhere yeah I
think they probably will
because if you look at my review I said
at the end I said it would have been
nice at the end of this game because
they literally had abilities from
Dishonored if there was something
connecting the universes in the actual
shift yeah that shift uh move that's
definitely from Dishonored so I think
redfall looks great at it I'm a huge fan
of Arcane and I think this game is going
to be amazing I think like I mentioned
before I think this game is a single
player game with Co-op
because that's what Arcane does and the
more they show this game I love the
horror elements I am excited for real
far
super excited
gonna I think the biggest thing I Gotta
See Is I just got to see more gameplay
like how things work I'm actually more
in like I'm what's what I'm looking for
I have a lot more hope because it is a
single player because I feel like they
could flesh out certain ideals better
but with these iconic characters like it
would have been nice if this was built
from the ground floor to be a co-op game
but there's a lot of issues when you
make a co-op game uh first instance like
I feel like a co-op game doesn't make
sense truly unless the gameplay is with
co-op in mind and I feel like some of
these people just throw a cop you know
mechanic in there and they don't put
that into consideration perfect example
we've been deprived of true co-oper
games so long the first time we got a
really really good one which was the one
that uh it takes two it got game of the
year
882 was freaking amazing bro that game
was incredible
that's what I want more from the
industry uh obviously I don't think uh
arcane's gonna give us that uh you know
the individual that does that's going to
give us that and I for that studio they
hitting everything out the park rather
thing that made it takes two but as far
as redfall
the ability to see to me this seems like
their attempt at making a lot uh a um
uh last uh what's that game with the
zombie
left for dead this is their attempt to
make their own version of Left 4 Dead
um it does look interesting especially
like the different Universe stuff where
like their nest are I will say that up
until last E3
when they opened with
redfall I wasn't anticipating redfall
whatsoever but I will say now they've
done a better job making me want to play
this game
yeah absolutely man um I'm I'm excited
for it now my homie Jason Max hey what's
up bro like you said um he can figure
out death Loop let me tell you something
I
had an issue with def Loop initially too
I was okay what the hell is going on
it's about I kept on playing it because
I trust Arcane Studios where I love
their game so I kept on playing it and I
oh I get what's going on now I
understand the game
um it is it's not a game for everybody
but once you get it I loved it
um I finished that flute so
I I'm looking forward to real far I
think it is it looks perfect but I I
didn't realize it was going to be uh
such a horror game because it really has
some deep horror elements do you yeah I
say do you think that they can like they
might have overstayed the capitalization
of the horror elements just because
we're around Halloween and stuff to try
to get it's possible it's possible
because part of me is like they're
capping a little bit with that because
they haven't really showed that kind of
side to this game whatsoever and now all
of a sudden around Halloween they're
shown every before it's like they take
every little scene that's in Hollow uh
that's in that that's in redfall that
can even be remotely like scary typing
though put it all in one trailer yeah
yeah that's true but it it's working
though it's working I Gotta Give score
on another try because everybody what's
up doc dog they saying scoring is um
good I gotta get a I have to give it
another try I put it down to play
plagues tales and got them Knights and
everything what you doing right now what
you doing right now up
you you you work you come in here and
give your balls for a couple minutes uh
if if dart's okay with that okay
that's the homie dart's approval man
can't have no one be popping up in here
you know uh I I do respect the people on
my podcast if they if they ain't feeling
it they ain't feeling it but all right
man like it comes a rifle I need to see
more that that's what I need I need to
see how the game operates as a single
player versus a multiplayer I like the
builds I like the stuff that they're
doing I just got to see it all put in
one thing I think that's my thing I just
got to see it all rolled up in little in
a little cake with a you know a little
bow on top I got to see how the finished
product is but yeah I will say one thing
red Falls starting to look like a very
good catch now I am curious to see you
know maybe with this Metacritic score
this game would be uh do you have a an
estimate let's let's do four point
estimate what do you think it's going to
be
it'll be between 83 and 87. yeah I was
gonna say 82-86.
[Laughter]
yeah I think 80s I think 80s very
possible for this game yeah and
depending if they do anything uh you
know different it might get a high 80s
yeah uh it just it just depends it
depends you know chat put in there man
four point difference you could put one
number if you want I'm giving you guys
four points if you want to do it what
you think the Metacritic score
for redfall gonna be I'm curious man we
might read some of them here in a minute
I don't know just depends on how the
podcast is going because sometimes I I
feel like doing something that bam I
don't feel like doing it no more all
right so we're gonna move on uh you know
we we oh I I would say that we we're
gonna have a short podcast but I have a
feeling that last topic will take a 15
20 30 minutes let's talk about this
remastered thing man I'm gonna put the
timestamp police in here for four to
four minutes on the dot that's where the
timestamp police getting
where do you okay here's my thing with
the remasters I think remasterers ain't
been this hot ever like ever been this
off right we got Resident Evil 4 coming
out we got Silent Hill I think that's
considered a sequel isn't it
I believe it's Silent Hill 2 we make
okay remake Silent Hill
uh you have the Alan Wake remake that
happened you have well when I was a
remaster remaster well you get what I'm
saying oh oh well again
yeah
you got the ho you got the
um
Horizon forbidden wet and a horizon uh
zero Dawn zero Dawn remake that's a
rumored coming around my question to you
dirt and then you got the perfect Dart
isn't that a remake
it is a reboot in well you get what I'm
saying my dog is a reboot though okay
what about what about Fable is that a
remaster that's a reboot oh so they're
just trying to do this they do too much
stuff man all right all right all right
so my question to you dirt is it too
much do you think people are going too
far selling old products packaged into a
nice little packaging for us and put it
back on the shelf for seventy dollars
that space coming out keep in mind
that's another one
um you might not gonna like what I say
it when it makes sense it's perfectly
fine with me
um Now The Last of Us didn't make sense
to me the game wasn't old enough
but a game like a Silent Hill
The Witcher um
the original Witcher those games make
sense those games are years old like
over 50.
yeah well that was a remaster
let me let me explain to you what my
definition of these are okay because
there's only one that matches mine all
right so I consider a remaster anything
that's coming out the original content
one for one uh mainly you can that one
for one thing can be up for debate and
it's just coming back at like a higher
frame rate you know retouching certain
Graphics that's what I consider a reboot
I mean a remaster I consider a remake
altering things that happen in the game
or expanding on things that happen in
the game and and restructuring it for
instance I consider The Last of Us Part
One that's a remaster to me I don't
consider that a remake because I don't
feel like they did enough to justify
that remake title I feel like it's just
a glorified remaster right
tiger
um
I'll tell you what's a remake in my
opinion Mafia
that was a remake great remake now the
reason I'm okay with remakes if a game
is old enough I never played the
original Mafia
never played it on the PS2 on PC or
whatever I never played it so when I got
it I was like wow this game is
incredible but it was today's technology
it was you know today's graphics and it
was fire
um games like Dead Space that came out
with a 2008
the game is pretty old
yo at this point so if you think about a
kid that was born in 2008 they're a
teenager now right say they didn't play
it back then because they were literally
a baby
they became a gamer
oh this new game let me play this game
that 13 14 years old now so I believe if
it's okay when it makes sense like
I'm I love the Dead Space we make
Resident Evil 4
um
Silent Hills all of those remakes are
are perfectly fine with me
my opinion I'm right there with you you
know it's funny you thought we were
going to disagree I am yeah I thought
you was going to say I felt like
anything more than five years is a no-go
for me for a remake if it's only been
five years
it reminds her put it back but I feel
like certain companies want that 60 70
price tag so they feel like glorifying
as a remake is going to be a better sell
than just putting remaster or Game of
the Year Edition right here it's just
like and what's funny is people are
trying to compare The Witcher scenario
to the Horizon and last of a scenario no
they're nothing they're nothing when did
the original Witcher come out
um so I don't know what year tell me
when the original Witcher came out
what's the point of the chat if you
don't correct my information
I feel like and you know what's crazy
Capcom is showing everyone that if you
do a remake this is how it's done or
shut up don't even know oh my God
attic I mentioned this before but
Resident Evil 2 Resident Evil 3 both of
those remakes I bought those games on
the PS1 I didn't finish those games for
whatever reason I think I was scared I
don't know what it was I didn't finish
those games back then but I bought those
games now the remakes were incredible I
loved them especially part two it was
fire bro and I finished both of them and
I never finished residue before so guess
what March 23rd I believe it comes out
I'm buying it and I'm finishing it
resident before looks phenomenal it
looks amazing and looks amazing bro I
feel like
this should be the standard like uh
Final Fantasy 7 remake Resident Evil 4
remake Resident Evil 3 to a point I know
a lot of people had issues but it was
still 2007. yeah that's the chat said it
like oh I was a chance okay because oh
okay I don't look stuff up man I got we
got over 200 people in here let them do
it we doing the show dirt uh so it's
just like I look at this and I'm like
this is what a remake is and now when I
see Studios trying to get away with
making remakes like PlayStation has been
doing with with The Last of Us Part One
it's like how are you gonna remake the
game but not fix stuff that people had
issues with because you didn't want to
spend that extra money on doing it
because that would have involved
building the game completely from the
ground up that's why they like
our Target games should like part one
will be a perfect candidate to be remade
Uncharted one
how come they haven't remade that game
I would love to see an Uncharted one
remake
but you know
I think that might be too expensive
because it's such an old game and
Playstation doesn't want to fit that
bill yeah and what's crazy you see
Resident Evil 4 Resident Evil 3 Resident
Evil 2 Final Fantasy VII
why are people okay with calling Last of
Us Part One a remake it's not all they
did was take the engine from from part
two and threw it in part one that's the
only thing they did glorified it's a
glorified remaster that's what I call it
a four five remaster yeah and it's and
it's low-key in my
mine like kind of like more uh what's
what I'm looking for like
not sabotage like convenient I'll say
convenient convenient marketing they
they needed just enough to make it worth
seventy dollars and they felt like
putting a remaster it's got 40 50
written all over it but if you say it's
a remake you could charge 70. and your
people are gonna sliver right up yeah
it's just it's it's sad like and people
sit there and like I'm tired of the
Remake no I want more I want but here's
the thing
calcoma showed you that if you go out
and you actually spend money and
properly remake your games people will
line up to buy it yep
I agree like that's I'm looking at games
like Badger Kazooie a proper remake
people would buy that I know people
would buy that
uh a proper remake yeah what what do you
what some what some fan favorites you
would like uh chat put some fan
favorites or some games you would like
to properly like a Resident Evil 4 star
remake if you could choose one game what
would it be oh
one game well they're they're supposed
to be doing a Sprint of sale remake also
but I will say
um I say Resident Evil one I would say
that I would like Resident Evil I would
like Resident Evil one to be remade like
that yeah absolutely Fallout 3 is a good
one
Fallout three right uh I would say
oh man there's so many uh there's so
many options bro
man I'm trying to think do you know what
game I would like to see remake even
though I don't know how they would do it
like uh Resident Evil but because it's
so much more action in it I love Prince
of Persia Santa Times bro
nothing I love that guy
on the PS2 I believe when they first
made for the PS2 yeah
at the end of the game or something like
that I believe so yeah I remember at the
end yeah but yeah I finished that game
and I love that game I love that trilogy
on the PS2 and the original Xbox I would
like a Crackdown remake like a proper
Crackdown remake here's the thing that
like people hold on wait a minute RC
young is hit on something do you
remember the suffering bro on the PS2
see I know you're much younger than me
but yeah
oh man you were this guy in prison and
the prison got taken over by these like
Monsters bro that would be a good one in
today's technology
RC Young
that's a good one bro I actually feel
like a good Prison Break simulator with
enough money behind it where you have to
actually like do the routines find how
you want to break out like like kind of
a it a ways out but just the beginning
of it is strictly like there's like
hundreds of ways to break out and you
have to like memorize stuff like I think
that would do well it's just I think the
issue we have here dirt is people don't
want to take the risk and I get it some
some studios that's millions of dollars
that you just might not get back
absolutely I feel like
we need to put this ball in Microsoft's
core and PlayStations Court uh you know
companies that have the money to lose
sure you don't want to lose that money
but I feel like if some of these
developers and Publishers don't start
pushing new ideas and pushing you know
games to be more updated then I don't
think we're ever we're not going to get
to a point where we're going to move
past anything we're just going to keep
rehashing old ideas someone said Fable
2. no I want a fable one remake I want
to favor these guys in a chat they are
dropping some jams though the chronicle
really that game was fire on did you
know
um Van Diesel owns the Chronicles
already IP like all of it
they wanted him to come back for Tokyo
Drift
and they were offering him like like
that for a camo for like eight hundred
thousand dollars or some stuff like that
just when I came out absurd amount of
Cameo and he said no you could keep your
money I want The Chronicles of Riddick
and that's the only way I'm gonna do it
and they gave it to him
wow that's how that's pretty smart but I
I guess what I mean but well he haven't
done anything with it
oh yeah yo they have some gems in here
uh
man
aside from Filter oh I listen I tried to
play the Empire filter yeah
I tried to play uh siphon filter on
Playstation premium
didn't age well man I would love to see
it remake of that game I was playing
like what the hell is that would be a
good game that's what Microsoft should
do they should Outsource and code
develop uh Studios with Bethesda to
remake some of these old Elder Scrolls
game imagine a rematch a remake of more
one coming exclusively to Xbox and PC
yeah that'd be pretty yeah I think they
should do that Alpha Protocol I never
played that game but I was in the city
game obsidian game that wasn't
critically acclaimed
but a lot of people but it was it was
like one of those games Veronica like a
cold hit
I believe if they do we make another
Resident Evil game that's the one
they're gonna do I don't think they
would do five I think they would do
cover Monica I like to do both I think
they would do five because here's the
thing I don't know if they would do five
on one thing but if they would I have no
if they making money they're gonna try
right but I think five would sell well
you like you you built because it seems
like they've took the old formulas from
these games and they've built on them
like times ten I feel like you do four
five and you build on that Co-op
experience even more than it was built
back then and it was a really good game
people don't give Resident Evil 5 enough
credit it's a good game it's just people
have and I get it more action they want
more horror out of Resident Evil and
I've always said from the start you are
entitled to that but it's dumb because
the reason that you got that much horror
stuff from the original couple is
because it was right there at the start
of the outbreak it was new you uh people
in the game in the lore of the game
didn't know what the hell was going on
once you get years into the outbreak
what are you gonna surprise people with
no everyone knows what's going on but
did they really see Chris Redfield and
think that it was going to be a horror
game the dude is the military he's in
the military like look they could have
did better I feel like you know that is
one game that they could do better when
it come to horror where they can do have
more like dark environments more like
you know you feel like it's the unknown
like it's not necessarily you know
what's out there but you know that
you're gonna have a hard time fighting
it like you're like uh Resident Evil 6th
I think Leon's story did a great job
reading quarterback uh but it's just
like look like
Resident Evil moved on from that and I
do think that they they acknowledged
they did because they went back in the
newer ones and they try to bring some of
that back but the thing is is you guys
got oh you guys got a fan base split oh
someone literally just said it after I
said it it's like the Final Fantasy
people have a fan base split we got the
people that like action based and we got
the people like turn base see I'm over
here and I'm dead eyeing these people
hating them because they ruined my
franchise
and you guys are with me man you over
here in the horror Resident Evil Dead
eyeing these people hating these people
guess what I'm these people in Resident
Evil so I like a good mixture of both I
do and I feel like I do Resident Evil
now because I played so I played five
and six as Co-op I see that more as a
co-op fun experience game that you take
on zombies with your friends I love four
fours four and twos tied from my
favorite I probably lean more towards
four because I like the gameplay better
but
they all have something to offer and I
think with these newer games
um they are showing that they're trying
to accommodate everyone I made a video
recently you guys can go look at it it's
if you look at something like Capcom
where they they forced Resident Evil
fans to play that uh as a as a first
person people hated that stuff I didn't
play Resident Evil Village because I'm
not playing Resident Evil as a first
person it just I try to bio shock or
whatever that game called biohazard it
just didn't feel right and so they they
heard after Village and they saw you
know I'm going to take credit for that
chat imma say my one cell was enough
actually I bought it never mind never
mind let me I didn't play it up on it
okay so they looked at that and they're
like look we why can't we just do both
when you start the game just give them
the option of choose between first and
third
I don't know if this is a feasible thing
doing at the beginning of a game so like
the next Resident Evil I don't know if
they're going to give you the option to
do it at the beginning but I would hope
they would because it would give the
people that want that third person fill
and first person Phil and it would get
both of them what they want what's crazy
and I don't know about you Dart but
Capcom is the only company that has
successfully brought their company to to
next-gen Hardware to next to the 21st
22nd century of like if you really sit
and you think about it
Devil May Cry
they successfully passed the torch in
ways you know people still love Dante
Dante's always going to be the goat but
people don't resent Neo or Nero or
whatever his name is Nero yep yeah and
that's hard to do you look at something
like Resident Evil 4 they have
successfully
oh look man I used to work at Dish
Network okay I got a lot of these okay I
got a lot I noticed that well I was
looking at that so you look at something
like um Resident Evil they went back
they remade the old ones and saw that
look
okay hold let's let's back up a little
bit they made the new ones and they're
like look people don't they like this
this third part this first person one
but then they started remaking the old
ones they're like but people still want
that third person feeling so we'll give
you those for that but then what ended
up happening is they saw the amount of
people that was buying the old stuff
when it was that third person view and
not buying the new stuff and they're
like yo I don't like that so that that
has to be what happened because to me it
makes zero sense to give people a third
person view on a game that's been out
for two years yep I agree I agree but I
will tell you this the scariest Resident
Evil game in my opinion was seven
because of the first person mode
and that creepy house with that creepy
family that was the scariest one
hey did you see the um the Super Chat
from Raiden blade I'm about to read it
you want to read it yeah I can read it
for you rain Blade with the five pounds
you guys seen Xbox defend Series S
basically telling Dave stop you crying
nothing is wrong with the series s love
your last video dirt and sorry I was
live on Monday
that was all good brother appreciate you
man
um did you get El Nini
yeah this network spots
yeah I could tell you you know what's
funny is like I would honestly say I
learned a lot of like like speech skills
from like doing podcasting because you
eventually have to like break that shell
being shy in any way shape or form like
I'm sure you can ask dirt the hardest
thing it to me I don't know about dirt
to learn about doing content is having
to talk to no one on a camera in a mic
yeah uh once you break that you can do
anything at that point you can do
podcasts because once you put a second
person into the into this way it's way
easier at that point but when you let
master and I and I'm not even joking
chat for years I struggled with that I
still struggled that to a point but it's
not easy to talk to no one it's like
you're talking to an abyss and you're
hoping they talk back like it's not an
easy thing yeah I agree man I agree
you like to spend two hours on a video
you edit the video
then you release it and then you get
five viewers after two hours like damn
yeah and you know I think
I haven't made a video in like four days
you know I was gonna make a video
I was literally gonna make a video once
a day for like 30 days that completely
tossed out of the window that's that's
strong I've done that before I've done
that before yeah yeah nice uh so I I but
I do want to make more uh
I want to see attic on uh I've been on
your show before one of them yeah I've
been on wbg yeah you've been on WBZ I
had to go on it was it was about what a
month of month and a half ago yeah I'll
go on your other one TTS well yes my boy
Sean Sean that's Friday uh that's on
Friday that's my boy Sean show um okay
I love them with the chat wants I guess
I Gotta Give it to
all right so let's let's
solo it man let's let's talk about
what's going on with the Xbox game but
we'll talk about generally all of it I'm
gonna give you guys an hour and we'll
say five minutes no yeah an hour and
five minutes so you know first off is
there anything particularly you want to
talk about of these stats that came out
is there anything that you want to talk
about with these stats
well
I think it's just overall
um to see that Xbox is still doing well
Xbox game pass subscriptions grew
Hardware grew 13
um I think it's great but it's one thing
I do want to talk about specifically
Satya Nadella said PC game pass
subscription have increased over 159
year-over-year
so I wonder how much the numbers what
like I saw a lot of people like clowning
on that like we don't know the original
numbers at that point I get it but we're
not gonna act like it's like 10 or 15.
I'm sure they got a little a few so
right you know they what they almost
quadrupled that
did I read that right well 50 would be
doubling 100 would be uh with 100 yeah
yeah so 50 would be half yeah that'd be
yes yeah pretty much triple whatever it
was um before but so I just like to see
Xbox
um
proving people wrong because even though
they're not beating PlayStation or
Nintendo they're still showing that they
belong they're still showing that
they're making money or doing whatever
they're doing to you know stay around
you know like we just said
there's so many different fast food
restaurants yes McDonald's is probably
the leader but that doesn't mean
yeah but that doesn't mean Burger King
windy Subway is is not making any money
so I'm just happy to see stuff like this
I think that PC game pass does have a
play some
what I like doing and I don't know if
it's on every game because I don't
really do the PC stuff too too much I
like when there's cross progression I
like when I can load in to a game on my
Xbox and then just load into the uh to
the PC version and start exactly where I
was
I like how cloud computing is around the
same thing like I was I was at my
girlfriend's house and I've been doing I
don't really
I have a video coming that's about cloud
computing
um
and I'm about done I I got to do this
trip because I'm going I'm going uh I'm
going away for for a week I don't know
oh is that gonna affect
the week that week's uh
no well we'll still have the uh the
podcast uh so I'm doing this video and
I'm sitting here and I'm loading into
Persona on on my tablet
exactly where I left off on on Xbox and
I just think that if they can get this
right 100 working everywhere because it
works fantastic on the Xbox yeah you do
the the streaming thing from the Xbox it
looks great it does it runs great no
issues
um and I'm saying if they think if they
can get this done right like done right
I don't think people really look I'm
right there with you guys everyone in
the chat that just does not like cloud
computing gaming 100 with you
I don't like it but I can understand
when I'm laying this
like y'all that's got a lot of potential
like just to be able to load up
going wherever you go and just play
wherever you are I think it's got a
great amount of potential what do you
think dirt yeah yeah listen like you
just said it works really well on the
consoles and I'm hardwired until my Xbox
series X and it works extremely well
like the only issue is like the
resolution obviously dips
but it runs really well
um when I still have my Series S I
wasn't even hardwired into that one but
because the Xbox series s hard drive are
so small they would be games I'm not
going to download this game oh hey
there's the cloud option let me play and
it didn't work good it worked damn good
so I think as long as it's the option
it's just the option
I believe it it has a place in in gaming
it's still in its infancy but I believe
it have a place
in-game I think it's good and I also
think that you know
people
don't
look we I remember a couple years ago I
don't know if you was around back then
dirt when they started because I've been
around so long I remember do you
remember the very first game that went
to PC
the very first was it no I don't know no
the Xbox started this oh yeah Quantum
break it was quite a break yeah yeah I
think it was the first game that they
did the what did they call that Pro oh
damn what do they call the guys I forgot
was wired but you buy one you get the
other one
yeah it was a certain program that you
bought it on one you got it come here
help me out guys yeah help us out what
was it I remember play Anywhere that's
what it was play Anywhere thank you and
they were having a lot of issues with it
on play Anywhere
um that was that was the first game they
did and you know what the only like real
XBox exclusive is Xbox One
what's that it's Halo 5.
yeah Halo 5 is still not on any other
platform
besides Xbox right well I think like we
Forge is on it but they actually foreign
at this point just make it like yeah
just Port the thing at this point like
what does it matter and you know
I don't know if you if you've heard you
know we ain't gonna get into that all
right so we're talking about that uh but
there is one other thing that I want to
like capitalize on and talk about it's
that they came out and they said the
Xbox game pass is profitable and they
said wait a minute
what did you say Xbox game passes
probably wait a minute wait hold up hold
up hold up hold up
you triggered my trap card
could you hear it yeah you triggered my
trap card
these guys told us Xbox game pass is not
profitable they told us these guys told
us that Xbox is losing millions and
billions of dollars daily and Xbox game
pass is now profitable whatsoever but
you know what's funny when this news
came out the first thing I saw a
PlayStation Fanboys say well it's not
making as much money as I thought wait a
minute you just said it was it wasn't
making any money it was losing money huh
oh my God
I love it brother the funny thing is
people sit here and they try to they try
to spend like they know how this stuff
works
I don't even know how this stuff works
you know I mainly just go out here and
freestyle everything right off the back
of the mine man I rarely have notes for
anything unless I'm doing a review I do
take review seriously like I'll have
like uh I know I have like Microsoft
Word on my right Monitor and like write
everything down and organize it when I
actually do the review
um when I was talking to people uh about
you know the way things are going they
said addicts people act like
cells people act like money can only be
made through subscription services and
money and game sales
that's just not the case
[Laughter]
oh you're muted
[Music]
oh my God
oh that's so funny I didn't know you had
one of those yeah man this is uh I
bought it from Amazon there's no does it
did it have like the PlayStation logo on
it no I bought the The Mask then I
bought the PlayStation sticker to stood
on
yo I'm surprised King Ain't bought one
of those
it's funny stuff man yeah so like people
sit there and they'll say that
you know that's the only way first off
when Microsoft bought all these these
products all these companies all these
IPS
was it to help Xbox yes but it wasn't
solely to help Xbox
people make Doom movies guess what they
have to talk to and pay now to make
their movies dirt
oh you're asking me yeah
oh yeah
Xbox hey you know Microsoft uh I'm sorry
they made Minecraft movie guess who I
had to talk to yeah they had to license
that out that's right you know it's just
crazy and P I don't think people realize
what's going on in the TV world they're
running out of ideals last year like it
they are making anything at this point
if it can make a story make it even
remotely okay they're like yo let me do
it let me do it please let me try it let
me try it like they will make a story
about anything these days and now
Microsoft owns all this IP that they
could just license to people and if you
don't think that those licensing deals
make a lot of money I got I got I got I
got a mud swamp to sell you
laughs
it's just
people ought to be more realistic with
stuff they need to stop
acting like they care that's the biggest
thing if you
if you have issues what Xbox is doing
and I can sense you generally care then
I will take your opinion serious if if I
sense that you're going out there and
you're saying stuff just because you
want
uh you know a certain audience to follow
you so you can get super chats often so
you can Captivate all of them so you
guys can sit in your little circle jerk
a circle and and just a PlayStation's
bad PlayStation's bad PlayStation's bad
like you know
I mean Xbox Xbox is bad it's just like I
got you you know kids move made a good
point I actually what's funny these kids
who said he needs something new on a
planet Xbox smooth just come over here
and join you don't have to do anything
with Planet X Box you can come on over
here here's here's my hand to you smooth
just come over here
[Music]
we we we could use a third seat smooth
we can use a third seat how would you
feel smooth if you didn't have to
prepare for a show ever again
ever again you just you just join it
isn't it night dark dirt when you could
just come in here and you don't have to
prepare for anything yeah man just come
here just talk you know because on
Mondays I got to prepare I gotta you
know I make my little Clips I do
everything you know just have my fellas
come in we just talk you do a lot I'm
surprised how long does it take you to
prep for uh for that show
I um I usually prep all week let me
explain
um for the end of the show
little like do you give a [ __ ] portion
of the show I'm literally copy and
pasting topics all week throughout the
week everything on Twitter I just
copy and paste something that said
Modern Warfare 2. disc on the PS5 is
only 70 megabytes meaning it's pretty
much a damn digital download yeah yeah
my code to actually load it on that yeah
um so yeah then then little the little
Clips I usually make um they don't take
too long I usually do them real quick on
my phone actually then just upload it
um but yeah it's it's definitely it's
definitely you know it can be time
consuming but it'd be worthless for me
it's it's worth it to see people like it
you know
all right so let's talk about the bad
because there there is some patch in
here and I feel like if we don't talk
about it yeah people are gonna act like
I'm I'm I'm trying to call you a bot
they can call you a bot man I mean I
don't care if they call me about uh but
they said Phil Spencer also said the
Xbox game pass on Console has slowed
down we see an incredible growth on PC
but on Console I've seen growth slow
down mainly because at some point you've
reached everybody on call so that wants
to subscribe
um that's cat
uh is your your subscribers aren't
increasing on play on Xbox because you
don't have no new content really on Xbox
the difference definitely the difference
between PCS you got a lot of people
coming in from the streets that haven't
played none of the stuff that's on PC
right that's on Xbox and they're
probably catching up a generation worth
of games in a couple months yep that's
what you're seeing over there but
console people let's be real here they
haven't done much this year uh you know
I I I've been told by some very good
sources that next year is going to be a
fun year for Xbox but this year we're
just gonna have to hold that L now
obviously they got some good stuff and I
I do think the Game Pass drops have been
a little bit underwhelming for me
particularly uh because you know I
didn't really care about like plagues
tell or anything like that last year was
lit for me when it came to Game Pass it
felt like every other week was something
awesome that I wanted to play but this
year I've been a little lacking and it
is what it is uh I don't really
particularly care for stuff like that
but it's just like
we have got to the point where people
are unsubbing or not subbing because
there's just nothing to play right I
think obviously that's going to change
when you start giving people content I
honestly do think there's going to be a
time
where Microsoft is going to have such a
huge spike in subscription rates that
they're not going to understand where
it's coming from because
right now
you do have a point where the the
context lacking so you're seeing uh you
know kind of like I call it like the
sprinkles from the dude from that that
one club that cut the stakes the salty
do whatever it goes like oh yeah yeah
you have like the sprinkles hit it like
it's all the sprinkles but I do feel
like if Microsoft successfully runs this
machine
correctly known as their first party and
they do what it's supposed to and they
run that machine known as Activision to
make some games exclusive but to push a
lot of game pass Day One games out
you're gonna see this go to this like
I agree with you I agree imagine some
Call of Duty every year starts coming
out day and day listen bro yeah I think
when you say that's cap I agree with you
we always talk about how in 2017 Fields
said they didn't want to show games too
early
but in reality they just didn't have
anything in the show because they had
nothing in development
so that was his way of saying yo we
don't have anything to show so he's uh
we don't like to show games too early
I agree with what you're saying he's
saying this console is is slowing down
as far as Game Pass subscriptions and it
probably is
but back to what you said well guys we
they literally didn't have a big AAA
first party game this year now they had
a great like um flame say some
consolidation prizes
I'm sorry because
consolidate
[ __ ] it
um you know I'm trying to say
um like plagues tell you know
um high that like high on life is about
to come out Persona just came out so
they have some stuff for us to play but
when it comes to first party consolation
I'm sorry it was to me I don't know why
I was when I say consolidation
consolation it took
um
first party triple A games is what they
need and like you said whenever Call of
Duty comes out
wow that's going to be huge and like we
always say addict those people's all
those casuals haven't upgraded on
Console yet they haven't upgraded
there's something I'm I'm sure they
upgrade it to the PS5 or the Xbox series
but uh this holiday I'm telling you
there's going to be a big wave on a new
next-gen console owners this holiday
especially if you see the Xbox series s
going for 200 dollars
I think we
we're we're in a treat man I you know
even when you don't talk about games
right now like look at all the stuff
that's about to come out like the next
six months to a year in gaming is going
to be something special I honestly feel
there's so much good stuff coming
um we are going to talk about Phil you
know what's crazy about this next
statements Phil kind of like they gave
him a bunch of different products and
said do you expect any of these to
increase uh in a certain amount of time
and you know Phil said that obviously
pretty much said that we're not immune
to price increases too yeah that you
know sooner or later we probably will
have to increase these uh there could be
a variety of things and you know this is
exactly what he said he said I do think
at some point we'll have to raise the
prices on certain things but going into
the holiday we thought it was important
to maintain the prices
um people automatically went with
consoles uh you know they're going to
write the console and I'm pretty sure
that literally someone came out Xboxes
and we're not raising consoles yeah this
is this is prices of games most likely
that's when they're going to jump to
their 70 and this is also
uh Game Pass description Game Pass
probably now
I think Game Pass standard the 10 the
999 I don't think that's increasing I
think that's probably gonna stay 9.99
yeah I think ultimately it's probably
gonna drop five dollars jump five
dollars and
maybe they won't increase it if family
plan does well like really well maybe
they'll keep it because family plan is
helping offset some of those costs what
do you think is a good price for family
fan I think 25 a month for family plan
yeah I think 25 is good yeah yeah how
many people four
four or two
when like when it comes to family I
would say four four
um a family plan yeah you know just say
like hypothetically your significant
other plays and two kids that's it
yeah I think I think that's fair it's
like look
things are obviously gonna go up I don't
think they're going to go up with the
console I'd be very surprised that they
went up with the console uh I don't
look just because PlayStation did it and
Oculus did it a little bit ago
it's not the standard we've never seen
that really happen in the industry yeah
never
never it was funny is people didn't
really talk about it that much so people
ignored it it's like when Sony raised
that probably tell me that tell me that
wasn't last week's news in a week bro I
agree I mean Us Xbox guys I I did a
video talking about it we talked about
it on the podcast but it seemed like
people just didn't talk about it that
much I agree with you because even the
media didn't really talk about it they
mentioned it yeah you know PlayStation
increased their prices back to you like
wait a minute man I ain't gonna talk
about it yeah like back to you Jeremy oh
thank you no it was like damn y'all
ain't gonna talk about it man um so yeah
that's something about it but I agree
that I don't think they're going to
raise the console crisis
it wouldn't benefit the many to raise
the console prices right now we're
trying to catch up to PlayStation you
know there
um but definitely console up I'm sorry
definitely subscriptions I can see that
because it happens every subscription
like Netflix went up several times
there's the plus I don't but they go up
yet
maybe maybe not but I'm sure the reason
these companies are able to sit around
is because the concert they deliver
even if Game Pass got to the point and
I'm not saying this would ever happen
where it's 20 a month as long as they
had the content to justify that twenty
dollars a month they can get away with
that yeah but they have to have the
content there's a reason Netflix
continues to raise their prices because
they're the only people delivering the
content that they're delivering let's be
real here look some other companies they
do give out good TV shows they do but we
can't act like uh Netflix does so much
so much content that first off they they
handle almost everybody there's
something to watch on Netflix for
everybody it don't matter anymore you
could be a weirdo and you still have
stuff to watch on there right two
they do when they find something that
works well they duplicate it and they
make other things just like it
um you know um the account the Academy
movie TV show um what is that show The
Academy no it's um it's with the the
mutant people in the academy what is
that uh the Umbrella Academy oh okay
great show I can probably name you five
to ten great shows that's been on
Netflix I can't do that with other
platforms right and that's the reason
they get away with this stuff because
for every one bad show they make they
make two to three good ones
and they make a lot of bad shows so you
know maybe now it's a little bit more
equal because if you're making more
content for more people you look at it
from a standpoint that's like yo I'm not
filling all this stuff because they're
making all this stuff that doesn't apply
to you just like Game Pass is doing now
you know they're about to release
um
what's uh they're about to release Age
of Empires on Console sure a lot of
people aren't going to care about that a
lot of people aren't going to care about
that but they did it because they made
sure to have that content for people
when it matters right okay I will get
super chats okay guys yeah I appreciate
it though uh two dollar scripture from
luckymo Microsoft holding back games
until ABK is done
I agree I actually think that Microsoft
holds back announcements because they
want to they want to seem weak yeah hey
bro I think redfall looks finished right
they'll be showing a lot of rainfall you
know what I'm saying
five dollar Super Chat from gamer by
choice you are not expecting Outlets
that uh uh that take Sony marketing
dollars to call it Sony are you Sony
make cut them off from review copies
great show you know what you ain't you
ain't entirely wrong there did you see
the dude that they didn't get he didn't
request the God of War code I might have
talked about this last week yeah yeah
yeah yeah they they have no problem yeah
they have no problem telling you no
right they don't tell you no they'll
criticize anything you say and what's
funny is I've been contacted over like
statements I've made in uh in games on
reviewing Xbox stuff but it's not like
negative quotations it's like a funny
part you know what I'm saying like I
remember in um
Forza Horizon 5 I posted on I I did a a
thing where I'm looking through the cars
because I made that as a I'm not a
racing fan this is the most casual
you're ever gonna get review and I said
when I was scrolling through the cars I
said now look at the cars you I don't
know any of them at all at all like imma
say Porsche I'm gonna say I'm gonna get
a Porsche because in
um Need For Speed Most Wanted I stole a
Porsche from from a blacklist Rider and
that's and he he thought that was funny
he's like you know that that's unique
you know we don't get a whole lot of
reviews like that kind of I don't know I
don't remember his exact words but it's
just like you know that's generally what
I've received from third party and Xbox
like I've I've been told by a few people
that PlayStation will criticize your
reviews
like their PR teams they're harsh and
that's probably why that's probably why
I don't talk talk to us I don't have a
god award review copy just saying I am
going to try to acquire one and I might
try to get I might have got a war like
three days early maybe four
I don't know but we're going to go ahead
and uh
uh see out the back door man you know we
we we had a good show let me go ahead
and uh do this times you know what's
funny someone made a comment because I
don't do the outro part of the review of
the time stamps in the outro
and I'm just like
you're not winning that fight
oh man all right man we're gonna go and
end this show you know I appreciate
everyone coming through we had up to
like like 260 65 people hit that like
button when on your way out you know hit
that like button
let's get it up there man
I got it I gotta show these numbers to
Cog and justify why we keep the attic
show around
yeah no I'm joking Carl don't really
have any input on the uh the attic show
too much uh my preacher ever coming
through bad start what can the people
find you man yeah check out my latest
video I'm definitely talking a lot of
trash about uh uh you know Xbox series X
um winning these comparison videos I
don't
they really hear
um you know anything about digital
Foundry a comparison base anymore I
don't know if you remember but in 2020
when the consoles first came out the PS5
was whooping the Xbox series access I'm
looking for those comparison videos but
they made fun of us when we said the
tools are coming but now I don't hear a
lot about
comparison videos from the PlayStation
but so yeah I'm just talking trash and
there's a check out my podcast on Monday
nights at uh 6 30 p.m eastern time we
had a great show last week uh like one
of my panel members Joey Kraken I saw
him in the chat earlier
we had a bet
um he said that Gotham Knights would get
over 80 Metacritic and I said it would
get under 80. so obviously I won and he
had to drink that egg live on air and it
was a huge yolk man he almost gagged it
was pretty funny so check it out man I'm
putting my um channel in the chat thanks
attic
yeah definitely go over there and uh
follow him man you need to put your
Twitter in there too oh yeah we can keep
up to date on everything you do uh you
guys can follow me on uh Twitter at Lord
addict ILP I am making more content on
YouTube Here recently you know I don't
know how long that's gonna last uh
sometimes I I like doing contests
sometimes I don't just depends what type
of mood I'm in but I what I what I've
been doing here recently is I've been
making because originally I was an Xbox
Channel and I'm not saying that I don't
appreciate doing Xbox content anymore
it's just I do feel like I'm getting a
little OD'd on it now so uh that's how
you successfully uh spam the chat by the
way uh
so you know definitely go there follow
uh follow me on YouTube gaming addict
I'm going to be doing a lot more overall
concept I will be talking you know
mainly about Xbox still but I will be
branching out a little bit into other
stuff you know I do kind of want to make
a Bayonetta video but at this point that
drama is pretty much over so I don't
think that's really going to do a lot I
want to I do want to talk about all this
this cell stuff that's going on so I'll
probably make that video talked about
Capcom you know I want to make more
videos that's not related to Xbox
obviously my main Foundation is the Xbox
brand but if you want to you know hear
my opinion on little things I think I'm
gonna start putting some top fives in
there uh definitely go to that as well I
hope you guys follow me on Twitter uh
Lord addict IOP you know we we I keep it
real on there you know sometimes I
sometimes I get in the in in the what's
what's the word what I'm looking for the
streets you know I start swinging at
people on the streets you know sometimes
I miss sometimes I get hit back just
depends but I appreciate it for coming
through and we'll we'll be back next
week hopefully there'll be more stuff to
talk about
there was a little bit to talk about
this week but it's the news is kind of
drying down a little bit which it
normally does around this time of the
year
um yeah that's why I like doing this
with with another fellow content creator
that's been doing this for a while
because we understand what to expect
there are times of the year when the the
news and just the overall viewership go
down because people are OD'd I just want
the Activision deal to be over with to
be honest
I feel like that's hurting content in
general because so many people are tired
of it but I appreciate it for coming
through this is gaming addict and dirt
griggity signing out peace out